nachgefragt bei gordon repinski form der
pioneer größe ganz herzlich und sieht
aus wie auf einem schiff bei ihnen oder
grüße sich ja so ist es wir machen auf
unsere deutschlandreise gerade stopp in
wolfsburg wir stehen hier direkt vor dem
vw werk haben gestern mit herbert diess
gesprochen und ja freuen uns auch auf
die letzten spannenden tage vor der
bundestagswahl treffen sie auch die
spitzenkandidatinnen spitzenkandidaten
und kanzlerkandidatin kanzlerkandidaten
ja teilweise haben wir das schon armin
laschet war schon zu gast bei uns in
köln da haben wir mit ihm über den
wahlkampf bei ihm den kriselnden
wahlkampf gesprochen er wirkte wirklich
auch noch so als wähler kämpfen und das
noch drehen mit eben diesem thema innere
sicherheit insbesondere und jetzt kommen
annalena baerbock und olaf scholz noch
als nächstes tut es gut jetzt werfen wir
mal einen blick voraus in fünf tagen um
diese zeit müssten wir eigentlich so
richtig wissen wie es ausgegangen ist
was ist ihre prognose ist kommt
die aktuell sieht es ja so aus als würde
die spd vorne liegen in den umfragen
sind im schnitt ungefähr 3 prozentpunkte
also die spd ist schon favorit im moment
darauf da am sonntag der wahlsieger zu
sein die union hofft natürlich noch dass
sich der abstand etwas verringert wenn
es vielleicht nur ein bis zwei
prozentpunkte sind dann besteht die
hoffnung dass man eben christian lindner
noch davon überzeugen kann in einer
jamaika koalition zu wollen die hoffnung
ist nicht ganz unbegründet denn
christian linder würde natürlich viel
lieber mit armin laschet regieren als
mit der spd aber je knapper es wird je
knapper die spd eventuell vorne werden
würde desto unklarer wäre es lastet
hofft auf die wende aber am ende ist im
moment die ampel die wahrscheinlichste
option aber wir wissen es tatsächlich
noch nicht so wenige tage vor der wahl
ja das ist noch nicht es kann sich um
ein paar pünktchen hin und her bewegen
und das ist das entscheidende ist es ja
auch immer die frage was passiert nach
diesem gong um 18 uhr weil dann ist die
welt eine andere
genau da wird es für die spd darum gehen
ganz schnell christian linder davon zu
überzeugen dass die ampel koalition die
beste ist für ihn wir gehen jetzt davon
aus dass es so ähnlich wie in den
umfragen dann tatsächlich auch ins ziel
geht also dass die spd vorne liegt und
dann geht es um eine geschickte
gesprächstisch dann muss die spd sich
überlegen mit wem sie zuerst spricht sie
wird dann den regierung auftrag haben
das hat auch die csu übrigens gesagt in
dem fall wenn die spd freunde liegt dann
hat die spd den regierungsauftrag der
und dann wird es in der reihenfolge
wahrscheinlich so sein dass mit den
grünen gesprochen wird und dann mit der
fdp und dann beginnt die frage wie man
mit der linkspartei umgeht da ist man
sich in der spd nicht ganz schlüssig die
parteilinke die ihr nun auch in der
parteiführung gut vertreten ist die will
mit der linkspartei auf jeden fall
gespräche führen das muss man vielleicht
auch machen für die basis dieses immer
gefordert hat und am ende ist das ziel
aber die ampel koalition also man darf
christian lindner auch nicht
verschrecken und bei der union bei armin
laschet sieht es so aus dass der sich
natürlich erst einmal über diesen
sonntagabend und dann durch den montag
durch die parteigremien retten muss
dafür muss er eine chance haben zu
regieren wenn das so ist wenn es noch
nach implico als wenn es entschuldigung
eine jamaika koalition noch als
möglichkeit gibt dann hat er vielleicht
eine chance und dann steht die union
vielleicht zusammen und sieht das
kanzleramt doch noch als zu retten
option sie haben jetzt so oft retten
gesagt im zusammenhang mit laschet was
steckt dahinter
armin laschet ist natürlich schon jetzt
in gewisser weise ein verlierer weil er
zehn prozent im moment unter den werten
liegt oder sogar noch mehr als angela
merkel bei der letzten wahl erreicht hat
als der parteichef wurde hatte er fast
40 prozent jetzt steht hat noch ungefähr
bei 20 prozent also das war ein
schwieriger ein problematischer
wahlkampf und jetzt geht es eben darum
ob die union das kanzleramt verliert
oder nicht die entscheidung wird für
armin laschet am dienstag fallen da ist
dann die fraktions wahl bei der union
die fraktionsvorsitzenden war das wollte
er eigentlich machen das will er
eigentlich machen und wenn er dann auch
stark in verhandlungen gehen wollte dann
müsste er diese tatsächlich dann auch
für sich entscheiden sich zur wahl
stellen aber es kann natürlich sein dass
am sonntagabend die dynamik schon sehr
in seine richtung geht wenn er
tatsächlich hinter der spd liegt dann
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dafür hoch
dass neben den sonntagabend oder den
montag in den gremien gar nicht
übersteht und dann am dienstag in der
fraktion bei der union jemand anders zum
vorsitzenden gewählt wird da gibt es
natürlich der amtierende ralph brinkhaus
aber eben auch jens spahn und friedrich
merz der eventuell noch beim comeback
versuch starten würde klingt alles
extrem spannend ganz kurz noch zum
schluss über die grün wird jetzt am
wenigsten geräte kann es seien
ja das ist so die grünen haben sich
natürlich in gewisser weise der
situation ergeben dass sie auf das
kanzleramt keinen anspruch erheben
können dass sie keine chance mehr haben
vorne zu liegen die grünen müssen jetzt
versuchen wenigstens vor der fdp ins
ziel zu kommen denn am ende wird es ja
auch zwischen den beiden partnern eine
debatte darum geben mit wem man sich
eventuell zusammen schließt wenn eben
beide optionen möglich sind ampel und
jamaika die grünen sind etwas
geschmeidiger die würden jamaika
natürlich theoretisch auch machen werden
lieber in der ampel das hat man auch im
letzten teil gesehen dass die grünen
eigentlich eine größere nähe zur spd
haben was die grünen nicht wollen in all
dieser geschmeidigkeit ist dass die fdp
vor gibt wer da mit wem koaliert also
dass ein christian linder danach
irgendeinem punkt sagen würde nein ich
habe keine lust auf die andere ich geh
jetzt zu jamaika da würden die grünen
dann auch nicht mehr mitmachen aber
ansonsten ist das ziel so stark wie
möglich ins ziel zu kommen wir dürfen
nicht vergessen die grünen hat nun über
10% am ende bei so einer bundestagswahl
es wird trotz der krise trotz des
abschwungs der letzten wochen das
historisch beste ergebnis für die grünen
werde höchstwahrscheinlich ja und dann
versucht man so weit wie möglich vor der
fdp zu legen und dann eben so viel wie
möglich von diesen zielen in der
regierung gegebenenfalls umsetzen zu
können das muss man alles gemeinsam
abwarten dankeschön für den blick ins
innere danke gordon repinski